what is happening there rejection well
what what we're gonna what can it work
what i could do halloween weekend yeah
so i brought tara erickson here who has
been making the festival rounds with a
horror comedy short film called kill
buzz a real killjoy craig that's the
name of it a real killjoy it's a really
good short film great some might say
according to the hollywood reporter and
variety
yeah
for sure they interview me all the time
yeah we've been watching some spooky
videos to put up for this weekend
because halloween we love halloween
these scary ghost photos why is he
yelling scary ghost photos rational
explanation you're not scary slipped him
you're not scary craig please tara
professionals are speaking are you sure
being met it's a good accent
everybody
everybody is she british
in september of 2018 two-year-old
fabiola rodriguez was tragically killed
her mother saundra gonzalez along with
other loved ones regularly leave toys
and other items on the beloved child's
grave
saundra was disturbed when the items
that she left for her late daughter
began disappearing she also noticed
other acts of vandalism at the gravesite
she asked staff at the cemetery to keep
their eyes open for anyone paying
unwarranted attention to her daughter's
grave
luckily for the family a nearby
gravestone has a camera trained on it
this family has also experienced
vandalism in the cemetery they believe
that their son's killer who is still at
large is responsible for the cruel acts
what they set up the camera in hopes of
gaining evidence to take to the police
they actually saw in the security
footage was truly shocking
images of a young girl about still
footage walking near their son's grave
oh my god concerned about a child
wandering the cemetery at night they
showed the pictures to the staff who
immediately recognised the child as
faviola
sandra who happened to be at the
cemetery that day tearfully confirmed
that it is her daughter in the photos
in one of the still images saundra
believes that it shows her daughter
walking away with a tall man who the
other family believes to be their son
what saundra is convinced that her
daughter came back to the cemetery to
lead the man to heaven
because both suffered tragedies so early
in their young lives the families think
that the kindred spirits have been drawn
to each other in the afterlife as
evidenced by the footage from the
cameras
oh
my god that is
absolutely chilling that's freaking
terrifying also why did he mention the
murderer who was apparently gonna show
up the murderer they thought it would
the guy was taking the stuff oh my god
scary and then i thought the murderer
was gonna mess with the grape that'd be
real dumb if you haven't been caught yet
yes i don't like it i like none of it
but i'm glad that the baby and the
brother are hanging out is not that
weird murderer guy okay i'm glad the
murderers ought to hang out with i'm
glad he's not he's just mentioned at the
beginning and then nothing comes of him
good stuff with families loved ones
being gone and then seeing like
especially the childhood that's sad
that's a really pretty clear photo
that's very clear i wonder if we could
see interviews with them to like look up
their names and be like is this real
like did they lose their baby yeah it's
so sad yeah why don't you do that oh
yeah watch more spiderman i'll hit him
up say hey listen send me some photos if
i need the real juice here okay
because i watch a spooky video with your
spooky daughter i need to know that she
was a real daughter in the first place
that won't be offensive
at all
viewer jasper ash bell wasn't expecting
any scary ghost photos when he went out
for dinner with a group of friends in
2013. unfortunately for him spirits
often show up at the most unexpected of
times
the group decided to go to a restaurant
near mulu national park in miri sarawak
malaysia this is one of the most remote
places in the area but the friends still
believed they could have a great time
throughout the night they took numerous
photos to commemorate the occasion it
wasn't until later that they noticed
anything amiss in the pictures
six friends were gathered that night but
much to their surprise a seventh face
showed up in one photo oh my god no
oh my
photobomb
god
the face appears near the bottom of the
photo tucked in between several of the
closely posed bodies holy junk based on
the eerie location of the face there's
no way that someone could have worked
without the others noticing how is
it seems unlikely that the face could
even be attached to a body oh my god
to the floor
the face itself appears human but not
entirely normal
head is cast in shadow appearing looks
like a zombie considering the bright
light that illuminates the others in the
photo
in addition its eyes appear to be
entirely wide giving the face a demonic
appearance it could be the photo of the
flash
no one in the group has been able to
explain this terrifying photo but it
seems unlikely they'll return to this
restaurant anytime soon maybe it's like
a siamese twin that's connected at the
guy's crotch totally and he's he's just
now coming out trying to make his debut
saying hey man i'd like some friends too
i wanna be in the photo with you guys
and everyone's like listen my friends
are not gonna accept you you know what
they call him right what do they call
him a [ __ ] oh
this is good
this is good well i'm glad i i don't
have a dick or a head down here
anywhere i'm glad it's nothing none of
that
you you've got one of those things down
there but i don't have it when you
really examine this photo it's like if
someone were to even cheat their way in
the frame like how do you do that you
have to go in between also the guys legs
are closed i know they're
i did not notice it in the beginning and
i'm like what are we looking for in the
second i noticed it i was like that's
terrible that is a terrifying photo that
is really actually very scary because i
mean maybe there is a way to cheat it
but it looks really hard that looks
difficult redditer i got ship to do
today never expected to see
golden retriever again after the dog
passed away several years ago
they certainly never expected to see the
dog show up in any scary ghost photos
yet evidence in a photo has made them
believe that their pet never really left
them
the dog's name was coda and she loved
the redditer's mother more than anyone
else in the family
the mother was distraught when they lost
the dog but eventually was able to move
on
however when her husband set up a trail
camera hoping to get footage of a fox
they got an unexpected surprise
the photo shows the mum leaning out of
the open door of the house's sun room
she's partially obscured by the porch
rails but she appears to be picking
something up from the ground
just a few feet is that the dog
oh weird
the spot is clearly in the shape of a
dog oh
puppy dogs
that makes me sad
if something corporeal had been standing
there she certainly would have noticed a
good word
because of the shape of the entity and
the close relationship coder and the mum
had the family believes this photo shows
evidence of the family pet coming back
to visit her favorite human in spirit
form
whether or not this photo actually does
show a ghostly canine the family can
take some comfort in the thought that
the dog may not be too far away
that was heartbreaking they're always
there that was heartbreaking i love
animals more than humans me too i mean i
love animals worth i love tara i love
animals more than
everything
yeah yeah i really just got one thing
one thing just me humans jesus christ oh
yeah lord and savior animals the holy
trinity terror yeah holy spirit you got
to fit in there because you put yeah
yeah it's a whole thing and he's whoo he
is obsessed with it you know i am
constantly yeah for me it's you know
animals and then like more more animals
and then like you know
craig craig here is he's just down here
you really got you had a rifle through
the trash to find his name in my book
anyway that was a really sad movie
i don't know it doesn't look real to me
though it didn't look that real i mean
you're like you outlined the dog and
made it white right now it made it
blurry yes overexpose it and blur it
they're like or it could be the new dog
that we got that looks just like coda
and we just photoshop yeah yeah over it
but if that really didn't happen that is
real i just want the doggie to get to
have some love
these are uncomfortable to do sometimes
naomi flynn never expected any scary
ghost photos of her very own however
that changed when something sinister
showed up in a photo of a young girl
naomi snapped the photo of the little
girl in the family's living room she was
standing in front of the television and
everyone who was in the room at the time
is certain that there was nothing
strange around that could have showed up
in the photo
yet when the film was developed they
were surprised by what they saw
literally the
black shroud appears to be hovering
behind the young girl
it's amorphous in shape but also appears
like a piece of black cloth yellowing
and floating in the air
with no legs what could have caused this
strange entity to appear in the photo
however the dark color certainly brings
to mind
i feel like it's fake i don't think it's
real she is taking the picture you'd see
her reflection in the tv and we don't
see any reflection of a person yeah at
that angle you would see her right there
in the tv no you're 100 got it covered
got it covered got it covered fake 100
next scary ghost photos aren't a common
souvenir that people bring home from
vacation
slapped ham viewer frank thieves was
certainly surprised by what he saw in
the photo that his sister brought home
from hawaii
frank's sister margie crosby visited
kawaii hawaii with her husband
at the beginning of the trip they bought
a small disposable camera to capture
memories of their vacation
on one of the final days before leaving
the island to head home margie's husband
took a photo of her on the beach in
front of a stunning background of sand
and sea
they timed the photo so no other beach
goers would be caught in the shot and
ruined the scenic photo
unfortunately something unusual showed
up to mar their shot at the beach yes
just behind margie oh what time is that
blue shirt what feeling backwards
folding
in a strange
it appears as if this person or entity
is bending backwards at a bizarre and
disturbing angle yeah a strange figure
doesn't even appear to have hands oh
that could be so fake that's what i'm
saying like when i saw it i was like
that's fake frank sent in another
picture that shows the original photo
being held up the image was developed
straight from the film of the disposable
camera
but i mean the photo was crystal clear
unlike many scary ghost photos that are
blurry or translucent
but margie and her husband are
absolutely certain that they were alone
on this part of the beach when they took
the photo
besides the figure appears so close to
margie that she certainly would have
noticed someone standing next to her
performing strange bodily contortions
but you can stage that also appears out
of place for a warm day on the beach
sure what could this bizarre figure be
the family has no explanation for the
entity and this photo has been haunting
them for years how's it though here's a
thought the reason why the clothing is
long and out of you know the usual
weather conditions is so they can fake
the photos so
that way they can hide their hands and
all that but it's like this person's
elbow is tucked in
back like you could stage that obviously
the person is very limber but you're
gonna wait till there's no one on a
beach in hawaii to get that picture of
her almost picking out a wedgie with an
arm and you can't even see her face
staged with your disposable camera come
on now i mean she should at least be
looking like she's about to take a cool
picture that you apparently waited for
it so that no one else was around it's a
disposable camera you're not going to
just it's not digital where is that
click
no no you're going to make sure you get
the right frame thank you stage stage
stage
get out of here go home leave never come
back viewing your disposable camera
stories ever again okay keep doing your
yoga proud of you that you could do that
i can't do that but also i'm not trying
to make fake photos but if you are
watching this video subscribe and click
that notification bell bring that always
use it you subscribe
adam lee's a manager at a security
company is used to spotting strange
things on cctv
normally it's criminals up to no good or
even employees causing trouble
however it isn't often that he spots
what appears to be a ghost
when adam got knocked
that was the photo
on a camera at a construction site had
picked up movement he immediately turned
on the feed from the camera to see what
was going on
much to his surprise there appeared to
be a woman in a long white dress walking
across the site
the dress billows out behind her in the
still image beautiful dark hair
she's carrying something wide in her
hands whatever the object is it's
impossible to distinguish from her pale
white skin he looks poetic
adam was disturbed by the footage he
pulled himself together to dispatch
on-site security guards to the area
where the camera was triggered
when the group arrived about three
minutes later everything was business as
usual they found no signs that anyone
was there or had been there in recent
hours
the security company is baffled by the
strange entity and adam himself has
admitted to having trouble sleeping
since the incident that's poor adam
supernatural aficionados have been quick
to label the entity a white lady a
particular kind of female spirit usually
seen in a long white dress
these entities are typically spotted in
less populated areas and often have
tragic backstories full of sorrow and
heartbreak
perhaps this spirit suffered a tragic
death somewhere near the construction
site
without more detail about the site's
history the woman's identity remains a
mystery
i should start wearing a white dress
there goes the white lady
that's me man all right guys you guys
subscribe to slap him but what do you
think of that one i mean
it sounds like they built it someone's
like hey just wear white dress and walk
we'll take a photo i feel like they
built a whole story around that one yeah
he's just he's just trying to get people
to sign up for his construction stuff
he's trying to get more sales he's
trying to get a tough time have you seen
me on the ghost channel he says he says
guys we gotta tell a really strong
narrative about how this traumatized
atom yes that is his character journey
disturbed paranoia he's seen the white
lady everywhere pull it together
suddenly pull it together adam snap out
of it he's having a hard time
right there's so much drama to his
journey i've been able to sleep with us
so now people feel bad and they're like
adam do you want to come build my
fountain and he's like yes
he's very busy
he's a very busy man sales went up for
adam that day
he better be paying her you know what i
mean because i mean she she made his
business what it is now she graduated
from stock photos to ghost videos
congratulations she did walk around in a
white dress in the middle of night
holding some handkerchief going did you
get it
uh there were a couple that were really
creepy in this one yes i agree well
thank you so much for being here
subscribe to slot ham love his channel
he's made some pretty amazing videos and
such a soothing voice subscribe to tara
i was playing the drums for you
who always covers these kinds of videos
fox foxy fox is the only patron of ours
that keeps in shape everyone else
unhealthy disgusting
they're relatable fox on the other hand
is this deity aspiration
reach this person every time you comment
on something i eat a piece of celery out
of shame and i poop
try to get the body like fox that's
right there's a lot of celery and
pooping
in five let's face it man you
are destined to whoop some ass one day
pull up some anus to prove this i have
set up some people to kidnap you you
will not know when it's coming you will
be thrusted into a battle royale
situation i got a lot of money riding on
you all this patreon money you thought
that you were given to us nope it's all
just being used to gamble
right on you to increase what you have
contributed our way so don't let us down
fox or i'll kill you myself
but i can't because i'm too puny
compared to your physical stature but
you could die trying
i will
like a fox like a fox
[Music]